Donald Trump did a wild Corona virus press
briefing yesterday, and instead of covering
it all in one story, I'm sort of going to
chop it up because there's actually so much
insanity that happened at yesterday's press
briefing that I don't want to just lump it
all together in one segment.
So we're going to start with one of the strangest
moments.
Donald Trump confirmed that he's really jealous
of Dr. Anthony Foushee and he doesn't like
the fact that people like Dr. Foushee but
don't like Trump.
What's fascinating about this is we speculated
months ago that the reason Dr. Foushee started
being pushed to the sidelines by Donald Trump
was that Trump didn't like the attention that
Foushee was getting, that Trump was jealous.
This was our speculation based on what we
know about Donald Trump.
Dr. Foushee was well liked.
Dr. Foushee was seen as authoritative on the
virus.
Dr. Foushee was seen as trustworthy.
Trump was not.
And thus we started seeing less and less of
Dr. Foushee.
Check out this insane clip where Trump just
says the thing that we all suspected.
Take a look.
In the world.
I have a graph that I'd love to show you.
Perhaps you've seen it where we're up here
and the rest of the world is down at a level
that's it.
Just a tiny fraction of what we've done in
terms of testing.
So it sort of is curious.
A man works for us with us very closely.
Dr. Foushee and Dr. Burgess also highly thought
of.
And yet they're highly thought of.
But nobody likes me.
It can only be my personality, that's all.
That's a president.
That's a 73 year old adult.
A wealthy adult, arguably in the most powerful
position of anybody on planet Earth who is
motivated by sort of playground elementary
school level nonsense.
Why do people like Foushee?
But they don't like me.
I'm the one who has Foushee working for me.
Well, Fouche, she's a doctor and he's trying
to save lives while Trump is just sort of
not a particularly bright guy whose priority
is getting himself reelected.
And this 35 second clip just explains so much.
This is a Trump mask off moment.
He's showing us he's dead jealous of Dr. Anthony
Foushee.
Earlier this week, we learned I mean, it's
all coming together now.
Earlier this week, we learned that when Donald
Trump canceled his plan to throw out a first
pitch at Yankee Stadium on August 15th, there
was really no such plan.
In other words, nothing had been scheduled.
Trump ended up canceling it, but there was
nothing scheduled.
And we learned that Trump only announced this
because he was jealous that Dr. Foushee was
throwing out the first pitch.
And when we went back and looked at the timing,
Trump claimed that he was going to be throwing
out a first pitch at Yankee Stadium just an
hour or two before Dr. Foushee actually threw
out a first pitch at Yankee Stadium.
This triggered Trump's jealousy so strongly
that he just made it up last week.
I'm scheduled to throw out the first pitch
and now he makes it very clear why is it,
you know, Anthony Foushee has such a high
approval?
I have a low approval.
People like him.
People don't like me.
Why is that?
The complaints of like a little kid.
He's just jealous.
He's extremely jealous.
And I don't know about you, but I don't want
a president motivated by jealousy.
And it comes out so strongly here.
And when we look back, it's so illuminating
because we have this movement in the United
States that for years under Donald Trump and
even before it goes back to John Kerry, actually
in in fact, the feminization of intelligent
and well-spoken men in American society claiming,
you know, this alpha male versus Beda male
stuff.
This has gone back a long time.
And if you remember the 2004 presidential
election, as many in the audience do, George
W. Bush versus John Kerry, John Kerry couched
as framed as the feminized man, the less than
really a man.
Why?
Well, because he went surfing once or windsurfing,
wakeboarding, something like that.
Because he spoke French, because he was educated,
because he was a Boston guy.
And the truth was, it was actually George
W. Bush who figured out a way to get out of
the military, like by their own standards,
which include the military military service
as a proxy to manliness and being a real man,
so to speak.
It was John Kerry who went to Vietnam while
George Bush flew a plane for a little bit
and ended up bailing pretty quickly because
of his privileged position.
And so we.
That was the first sign to me, and I'm sure
it goes.
Back longer than that.
But that was the first race where I really
saw this completely backwards.
You know, they framed the left as feminized,
not real men, even though the reality is it's
they who avoid the stereotypical manly things
like military service.
And then we saw it with Barack Obama.
You know, law Professor Obama, who likes music
that is less than totally masculine in all
of this other stuff.
And the epitome of it is really Donald Trump.
I mean, this alpha male beta male stuff has
exploded during Donald Trump.
And Donald Trump is the epitome.
Sorry.
Donald Trump is the antithesis, the antithesis
of what they claim makes a manly man Trump
figuring out ways to get himself out of military
service because of his bone spurs, which many
people don't really take seriously.
And now, once again, is it masculine to be
endlessly insecure and say, why do they like
him but not me?
Is it masculine to be so fragile that you're
constantly having to attack others?
It doesn't show strength to me and very, very
revealing that Donald Trump really exposed
what is underlying a lot of his Bahah bizarre
behavior and has been for a long time now.
That's part one of this three part analysis
of yesterday's press briefing.
Then it got even weirder when Trump told a
black reporter that he looks like Michael
Bloomberg.
Let's look at
that next.